[Musique]
bonjour le combat des chefs et la
première émission jeu de cuisine à la
télévision aussi vous devez la regarder
qu'un certainement un jour vous serez
invité à y participer pourquoi pas car
cette émission s'adresse aux cuisiniers
amateurs aux inconnus des fourneaux aux
cuisiniers du dimanche et par
l'intermédiaire d'un marché imposé mark
bayonne va nous décrire tout de suite
d'ailleurs eh bien nous avons
aujourd'hui une baudroie appelé dans
certaines régions lot de belles
langoustines des petites courgettes et
les épinards et avec ça messieurs vous
devez nous faire un joli plat alors nos
candidats du sien qui fait quoi autour
de la cuisine que je suis journaliste
journaliste et jacques qui est ingénieur
il est donc de vrais amateurs jamais
versées dans les métiers de bouche vous
le jurer j'aurais bien
alors qu'est ce que vous allez nous
préparer jacques je vous préparez un
sauté de veau droit au coulis de
langoustines accompagné de courgettes
farcies au m
djigo de la mer l'autre partie alors je
crois que le chef vous réserve une
surprise car c'est trop facile il va la
surprise du chef clova rives du cher
nous avons ici 4,4 produits il va
falloir que vous sauviez donne de ces
quatre produits obligataires monde à
votre cents ou moins laissez moi qu'est
ce que c'est alors nous avons des
oranges des lavez les poivrons rouges et
du safran
alors messieurs à vous de choisir peut
vous servir des quatre si vous voulez
une des cinq plus ou moins loin ok alors
on vous laisser au père vous paraît le
top est donné et vous avez le même temps
pour réaliser devant nous vos recettes
allez y messieurs les squatteurs excès
laurent nous sommes au lycée hôtelier de
bonneveine et nous avons chaque candidat
un élève du lycée public sur deux commis
ou candidats se croisent les armes
actuellement et sont en train de
découvrir une l'autre où le bo droit on
pourrait employer l'un des deux termes
durant cette émission c'est exact chez
le poissonnier vous trouvez la baudroie
vous ne trouvez que la queue on a enlevé
la tête et celle ci se trouve être
entière et vous voyez que c'est un
poisson qui a quand même une tête
monstrueuse
ça pose évidemment quelques problèmes
pour l'enlever quand on n'a pas le vent
n'a pas l'habitude de benjamin le
hachoir un choix et jacques j'attaque
shishir des attaques sont dans ce que je
vais faire avec vos surprises
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
voilà vous avez appris main ce qu'il
faut comme instrument intérim a coûté un
peu de la coupe et ancien hein voilà on
peut demander une conseil au chef il
continué
alors il faut montrer une chose sur ce
poisson je ne sais pas si franck ans
dont nous pouvons nous montrer cette
partie de la baudroie c'est un leurre
qui lui sert à pêcher et un agite seul
heures devant sa gueule et le poisson
qui essaient de beaube est ce cette
nourriture est avalée par une
contraction respiratoires de la baudroie
c'est quand même entre eux pendant 101
réparation que rapport à son corps c'est
assez important et on peut comprendre
que les poissonniers hésitent à mettre
sur l'étal sur un animal préhistorique
comme celui-là c'est un poisson que les
pêcheurs appelle aussi le diable diable
de mer effectivement il a vraiment une
tête de satin bleu c'est vrai oui non
plus pour dévaler une nageoire là un
jour lui servent d'ailleurs un marché il
ya 120 les faux là que vous pourrez
peut-être récupérer
alors nous deux candidats sont en train
de faire partie sont bien partis et
jacques est en train de sortir le foie
qui est un morceau de choix dans l'ordre
avec les joues je l'utiliserai voix
semblable jeune homme dans la sauce soit
pas prévu qu'il faut dix marques que le
soin est un manche le soit dans la
baudroie malheureusement trop pas
toujours le cas d'angers et bientôt en
fait il ne faut pas simplement parce que
les pêcheurs
le garde pour bien souvent sont des
connaisseurs voilà quand lucien vous en
sortez la wii c'est difficile ben euh
demande de demander quelques conseils si
vous voulez c'est assez inédit pour moi
mais bon la lavande après l'amérique
vous les jours mais qui pour la poule
voilà pourquoi la date de la tour vous
avez des défis l'amendé place qui leur
revient de temps en temps vous tirer
dessus
je vais pas vous c'est un torchon et
sans travail tient tout seul voilà une
peckham
merci cher alors la baudroie dit de
rechange communiqué la gueule de la
baudroie c'est un monument assez
extraordinaire il faut le dire
lorsqu'elle où ça gueulait le gogo l'a
pas remarqué
je peux d'ailleurs le garde manger bien
dormir demain et les dents qu'elle a
dans l intérêt du palais la sardine là
qu'est ce que c'est un caillou auquel
cas le calcul cela les dents sont
acérées comme des ardillon et la
prendrai pas part au soir tiédeur je ne
m'aventurerai pas mettre mon doigt
l'intérieur car il risquerait de qui est
vraiment monstrueux rien donné
c'est une norme regardez la cavée ratio
n'arrive à voir ils sentent trahis
c'est un animal vivant diabolique mais
très bon alors et alors là les oreilles
de méphisto réussissent tous c'est le
diable c'est le diable dans la sexualité
que surya rien le geste est assurée
et alors pendant ce temps votre jeune
commis nous le temps des achats lot qui
vont arriver en servira qu'à revenir
avec du beurre bien et puis je vais
ajouter du vin blanc et et en tout et je
ne peux pas un petit à petit forme de
poisson avec les joues de cette bête
c'est ce qui m'a offert le fond qui va
vous servir pour faire votre pour pro
chez rocher sens pour faucher d'abord le
poteau et faire la chose après bien mais
là les joues à laurent c'est encore un
problème bien je crois qu'il faut
d'abord que vous en devient peu la peau
voilà
bon alors lucien et tout en extrayant
notre jour vous nous dites en quelques
mots comment vous allez préparer ce
poisson là c'était voilà je suis
l'antenne de récupérer les jouer comme
les tombées de la lotte et je vais faire
un point des passions avec et lorsque
sean lorsque cela sera cuit le foie ne
pourra me servira pour la farce et
l'aube où l'on va servir va être remis
sur les exploitent et le beurre qui sont
venus avec un peu près un quart de vin
blanc pour pocher la route et je suis
toujours horaires et lieux le soir
monsieur chercheur à la change très bien
voir les i alors ne perdez pas de vue
que vous avez vos produits surprise dans
ce panier 1 pour y revenir il ne pense
qu'à ça nous en rêvons
c'est quoi comme fusent quelle
souffrance et choisir lucien dans les
ingrédients surprise powervu lille avait
démarré ta mère eh bien on vous les
donne aux siens on vous les offre la
maison vous les autres c'est bien les
mains de la boue mais en plombant de
garder pour chaque cylindre et déjà que
vous quel est l'ingrédient surprises qui
vous inscrire les ingrédients surprise
ballon rouge à l'orangé palois où les
poivrots sans doute ses pouvoirs nous
allons utiliser d'une manière d'une
autre bon et peut-être il avait le
safran non ça va pas mais vous pouvez en
prendre qu'à eux et le safran ça va pas
avec ce type de recettes
alors si j'ai bien compté les favorisera
les poivrons trouve un oui je pense ce
soir les poivrons et les navets pouvait
avoir quelques navets si vous vous êtes
retrouvé la vessie je veux si je vais au
point d'ici la fin de mon plat bonjour
maillon vous est demandé une fois
jacques ce qu'il fait là vous êtes en
train de nous préparer alors là
commençait le plus de poissons et là je
fais sauter rapidement assez rapidement
derrière c'est parce qu'il sait pas
celui-là le péter milliken les
pollutions des eaux vont le jouer french
à l'autre se fait rapidement les langues
bien doté 15 heures réservé quatre jours
la présentation et vous parce que le
vont sauter je vais réserver le
jus de deux puissants je vais le faire
tomber au cognac et ensuite je vais les
décortiquer le garderait les que pour le
plat pour le search de vionnet et je
vais me servir de tous les échos les
pâtes etc pour faire
le cool it le coulis de langoustines
c'est une espèce de
2 bis que
c'est le principe d'une sauce américaine
à la différence aux élèves de la langue
au son de leur métier alors vous s'il
fallait que vous connaissez votre
affaire
allez les jeux belote vous pose un
certain point lucien est en train de
faire une opération à coeur ouvert
vous étiez vous vivez vous ces jeux de
lattes les yeux et les joues à des fonds
de façon très bien le match derrière qui
effectivement c'est pas facile à enlever
des génies plus des jo de là mais on a
fait une entame de chabrol envoie ça
fait cartilagineux bien sûr dans chaque
émission du combat des chefs nous
invitons à un chef un professionnel un
cuisinier claude bertrand chez qui nous
sommes aujourd'hui face bertrand qui est
un professeur du lycée hôtelier de vos
nouvelles bonjour claude voyez on est un
petit peu envahir votre votre cuisine
vous connaissez les cobistes sont des
élèves de chez vous alors que peut-il
faire pour devenir cuisinier il y a
plusieurs options il y a toujours une
option très professionnelle rentrer en
apprentissage de 14 ans dans un
restaurant sous les ors de gmail par
exemple
et puis la formule lycée suivant
l'option choisie c'est deux ans ou
troisième d'information professionnelle
voilà nous commis sont en quelle année
le comice ce sont des deuxièmes
bt h ils sont rentrés chez nous l'an
dernier 2e années passeront leurs
examens l'an prochain et qu'est ce que
vous pensez de nos candidats vont très
bien ils sont très très bien rapidité
d'exécution ils ont une certaine
assurance et déjà je crois que nous
avons affaire à des candidats de valeur
je languis lors de la dégustation oui
parce qu'elle manque
il faut expliquer nos téléspectateurs
que tous les plats seront jugés suivant
des critères professionnels quand même
alors nous allons juger ces plats sur
d'abord sur leur présentation sur
l'originalité c'est à dire s'il ya des
idées nouvelles à dégager et bien sûr
sur la dégustation
les trois autres ont le droit de vote
avec des coefficients différents puisque
nous ôtons là l'originalité la
présentation sur 20 et la dégustation
140 sûr que je crois que c'est bien
lotis libre et c'est la finalité il faut
que ça soit bon avant tout moi que
je crois qu'il faudrait voir un peu où
en sont nos candidats car ils avancent
vite
je vois que les épinards eux ils
avancent à grand train
quant à jacques de votre sauce là il a
bien commencé comme toi ne doit se faire
elle se fait du spa on a essayé on a
ajouté le pu mais on a ajouté le vin
blanc
on a cassé les corses et les plus jolies
à l'oeil on peut expliquer comment il
fait le coulis de langoustines ça va
bien oui on fait d'abord
revenir donc les langoustines entière
rapidement parce que son et bestioles
qui puise très vite grober donc on
retire le beurre au garn ont fait
flamber au cognac uniquement et longhi
survivants ensuite
on retire les langoustines dans les
décortique on conserve les que
décortiqué pour le
ragoût enfin pour le centre est lui-même
on reprend les coffres les pattes
et tous les abats que l'on il est
que l'on remet donc dans la cocotte avec
le premier jus de cuisson
on peut revenir dans ce jus
des oignons émincés des carottes
émincées du céleri un peu de persil on
ajoute donc les les copies les excès en
outre le vin blanc le fumet de poisson
on va laisser cuire environ 20 minutes
pour ça que tous les sucres
des langoustines passe dans la sauce et
ensuite on passera au tamis s'adonnent à
ce moment là une sauce assez liquide
qu'il faut laisser réduire
et avant de servir on
ils craignent cette sauce on la laisse
traduire près mais et éventuellement ans
la montrent ensuite au
au beurre si vraiment aller très
liquides et si après d'autres solutions
en l'amour est un peu au beurre manié
mais si on peut éviter la farine dans
tous les cas où les vite ce qui me
concerne ce n'est ni très vraisemblable
bon écoute et en montrant à tout à
l'heure lorsque j'ai oublié qu'il
fallait ajouter un peu de
coulis de tomate ou un peu de tomates
concassées pour donner la couleur
omar à la sauce très bien
j'ai pas les langoustines de lucien j'ai
pas encore bien saisi par contre je vois
très bien vous verrez
notre ami jacques reix avec sont rudes
de langoustines les langoustines peut
nous rappeler ce que comment vous allez
les bleus je voulais disposer sur marche
aux dernières élections dans un petit
con vu en temps voilà très bien je
disposerai décoratives on leur dit le 4e
bouquet et puis plus jamais chez de
faire le milieu de la vente avec
quelques vieux vichy le combat des chefs
continue bien sûr avec une parenthèse
froide marque peillon combat des chefs
comme un plat froid c'est un peu froid
dans ses salles et uniquement de légumes
de notre jardin vous avez des poivrons
des aubergines des courgettes
selon un professionnel c'est l'oeuvre
d'alain couleurs très bien bon voilà bon
écoute et on va rejoindre nos chefs à
nous qui sont des aviateurs vraiment
dans l'air alors qu'est ce qui vous
arrive et lucien quelques feuilles
intacte de d'épinards à est ce qu'on
peut avoir quelques attaques directes
habits chics aux bonnes pratiques au gel
à michel maes et là c'est bon ça marche
alors qu'est-ce qui vous expliquer un
peu ce qu'il ya dans votre femme vient
du show biz ou les épinards une cure et
de véhicules
mais tant que je vais ajouter quelques
courgettes et du basilic
ça sent très bon
vous en êtes où moi ma force
comme quand c'est fini on a sauté ça
réduit toujours gentiment ça ça va du
lot de gens qui meurent
comme restait un peu le poisson quand
même de temps pour arriver à 100
caractères écoutez trop pour bien le
voir je vais d'abord le laisser encore
cinq dix minutes comme ça ensuite je
vais la tamise et pour la consistance
définitive au tamis éventuellement
l'accord encore un petit peut réduire
avant de la crimée si la première pour
le premier prêt nage de suffisant au
niveau réduction je montre un petit
commerçant
sinon ça aurait duré déjà fait main et
que l'on montre grâce au logiciel je
crois que vous voulez des épinards tout
frais tout beau les oiseaux étaient
transplantées enfance au 14e siècle est
emporté par là par les arabes ont semblé
disciplinaire qui sont plus récents ils
sont déjà dans la côte est très riche en
fer et bien cela va me servir pour
gagner un peu autour de la vente un pas
beaucoup mais avec line avait d'ailleurs
à l'énerver vous avez placé par des
données que vous avez vous vous demandez
le même plat ça ne coupez pas la force
de le répéter il a figuré par le réussir
bon et du coté de jacquet se passe
comment alors et bien des côtés déjà que
nous sommes en train de passer la sauce
c'est bien ça un emprunt de deux filets
des carcasses de ses langoustines qui
ont puis
dans le fumet de poisson pour enlever
tous les justes le sucre qui donne la
nouvelle ce bout de
le crustacé a secoué l'île écrevisses et
lorsque ce sera passé au réduire à 7
soit son corps un peu sur la camorra et
on la mettra peut-être au beurre
l'appareil dont vous vous servez c'est
un chinois tient qu'à nous vient
l'origine ou simplement parce que c'est
à l'apprendre d'un chapeau et le pilon
voilà c'est bien je vois que tout se
passe bien oui ça prend bonne place
après une belle couleur et bonne odeur
bien je crois qu'on approche d'une
approche du dénouement et on pourrait
peut-être rappeler les recettes sont
faites en ce moment par les cars lila
alors jacques nous fait une lotte au
bisque de langoustines et lucien nous
fait une lotte au court bouillon avec
des courgettes farcies et ils sont
partis tous les deux il faut le dire
avec le même panier ap le val panier
point produit et est identique des deux
et finalement ils arrivent à faire dans
le même temps des plats tout à fait
remarquable apparemment 01 dégustation
nous verrons à la négation
je vais faire jacques là ce que nous
montrent each other des plongées telles
officines a expliqué marc bâillon qui le
professionnels préfèrent les courgettes
farcies au moins une par son ex une
farce
dans laquelle il n'entre aucune viande
ou aucun gras
venant dédiant dans laquelle peut
rentrer donc pas du poisson soit
uniquement du clan des légumes ça va
être le cas
ce sont de langue béti courgettes
locale
du pays de saison je vais donc que des
groupes et sur le tiers de leur diamètre
je vais ensuite les creuser oui et je
vais conserver donc je vais creuser donc
ça je veux garder la voilà ça c'est bon
ça c'est super ça c'est du professionnel
voilà alors donnez moi votre petit jeu
voir si j'arrive à le faire et donc
j'ajoute
non je pars si c'est qu'on jette alors
ma force
ma farce donc j'ai fait tomber les
épinards
la loge il était donc très dur de volume
rapidement après avoir soigneusement
nettoyés qui est rafraîchie ensuite ces
épinards gelé ses soutes les eaux ont
peur en même temps que la chair bri de
ses gonds jette je lui ajoute des
échalotes que j'ai fait fondre pratique
là où robert et une petit duc salle de
champion paille puisque les champions
alors oui ça c'est le marché commun
j'arrive et lucie avoue beaucoup
rejettent que vous allez en faire alors
danger la seule la rupture
non mais les gens pour 26 revue pour
leur part oui celle-là me servir pour la
foire c'est plus couper là pour parler
l'animal avec sa vie donc et les
épinards donc là on a vu avec jacques
les entrées dans la pince maigre
évolution les épinards non mais
finalement très bien donc tous les deux
marques ont utilisé sensiblement les
légumes la même manière je pense une
différence c'est que moi je prends mon
album il boira du sien à me retrouver et
agneaux nés le sud comme je suis loin
d'être un professionnel
mais enfin on a eu droit un droit de
jérémy quelqu'un aurait ses notes bien
sûr et son son timing
on peut y ait une expression bien
française messieurs c'est le top
on va dresser
c'est le moment de vérité
aulas est
hendrix sociétaires
non
ils sont très sérieux
très bien mais vrai chez moi
faire
ils ont plein de bonnes choses on a un
goût artistique évidente boire
testicules dans la présentation est
assez séduisant dans son vin
thomas vert
je n'ai qu'un regret c'est très chouette
oui
et la présentation et sur assiette sur
place rectifiez vraiment inventé la
présentation d'aujourd'hui
pour moi que jacques amyot préféré
l'assiette du cir de manière un peu plus
classique mais dans une présentation qui
est quand même fait très coloré très
écologique a préféré le torpilleur
cessant de tempérament
et il lui serait légèrement handicapé
par un patron doit qu'à laisser couper
au pour des épreuves les blessures de
guerre
ouais là on touche on touche au but
encore
ce temps pilleurs il faut bien dire que
l'on a tendance à abandonner
le salissures plein en tout cas tu
envoies raison ça c'est en tout cas la
présentation évidemment est notée sur 20
l'originalité sont bien sûr mais
également et la dégustation sur 40
parce que
ce qui somme toute normal dans la mesure
simple avant aussi beau soit-il faut-il
qu'ils soient consommables plus que ça
puisque ça aujourd'hui
nous chefs s'activent dans les dernières
secondes du jeu messieurs il voit ce le
plus beaucoup de temps pour terminer
votre présentation chacun envoie une
langoustine faso
on espère du ciel
le des épines en parfait
messieurs pour l'ultime combat tu m'en
rende compte au chef d'oeuvre septembre
aux bravo il ont fait de même chose à
voir
bon appétit bien monsieur roulier je
vais vous annoncer les notes que vous
allez pouvoir inscrire alors pour lucien
14 16 32 pour jacques 17 18 36
le sien
15 16 34 jacques 18 18 37
lucien 14 14 30
jacques 16 18 34
le sien
15 15 30
jacques 16 17 33 lucien 14 15 30
jacques 17 18 36 est auto
[Musique]
mais quand tu es bon compte et burqa
par 149 ouais ok merci
bien comme dans tout combat il faut un
vainqueur
le jury alain donné comme vainqueur
monsieur jacques à qui je remets cette
magnifique marmite 3 qui brille de
nouveau dix fois la couronne du chef
bon voilà
[Musique]